du stand so schön ja
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu skyline
park elften bionik das nicht schlagen
hey so ich baue dieser baum vom jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen schöner und dann
wollte ich tropen mein cacau toten
setzling blatt noch nirgendwo
ich schaue mir noch in folge habe ich ja
meinen job angenommen ich bin jetzt sehr
pharma- und braucht nur noch ohne auf
dem land und wenn nein aber ich wohne im
land was machst du wenn ich jetzt noch
vier samen nein viel fleisch bekommen
dann bekommen wir unsere fahrmaschine
was brauche ich hoffe das ist auch so
eine automatische farming maschine ist
stell dir vor das wäre eigentlich
ziemlich praktisch weil ich meine seine
automatische koppelt warm war ein
riesenschritt für uns alle in richtung
zukunft wenn es auch noch automatisch
wäre dann ist schon luxus muss sagen was
du gerade die halbe haltbarkeitswert für
einen club darauf gehen lassen
und weißt doch ich dir gesagt habe jetzt
kommt weiß noch ich gesagt habe dass wir
sonst noch brauchen
hab ich vergessen hast
ein bisschen länger
danke so ich baue gerade einen
extra-raum die raum kann man das nicht
nennen so einen extraplatz wie viel der
alte herr weiß ganz richtig gut helfen
beim anpflanzen
der wirbel ist wie so was meinst du er
sagt es erst mal traten bei ihm kann man
alter also schon mal die texte geben wir
richtig viel das nice deswegen wollte
ich ja letztens so viel sticks von dir
haben rabatt bekommen sogar aus
klinsmann bekommen wir wieder normale
kinder und er daher auch nice hast du
schon gesagt stimmt ja wir haben es
irgendwie aus kakteen können wir sand
machen und erzählen kann man die farben
besser ist und sich sagen kann man sand
machen bei dem typen hier haben wir
einen kopfschuss wenn die familie preis
hast du gemacht ein niedriger preis
ja das einzige wasser gegeben wir sind
glaube ich gewisse sachen oder erwartete
ergebnis gibt uns crops pumpkin sieht
vogel kennt und paper was brauchen wir
davon nichts
ich muss man ganz kurz gucken wie ich es
jetzt bauer so wir brauchen diese
komischen haben hartplätze ja ja ja gut
ich habe schon
miami medical discover das heißt vom
alter wir haben richtig weil ich viele
jobs bekommen gerade möglich aber auf
christen dann auf jobs auch so viele
christoph dass jobs retten doch jobs
auch noch extrem sexy jobs ok über
wochen kaktus und das haben wir beides
nicht oder aber dies bewusst dass die
jobs nicht machen muss sondern nur
machen kann machst damit du so ein paar
sachen eintauschen kannst musst du nicht
machen aber muss sie machen in den bus
rein zu kommen
dann musst du eigentlich schon machen
okay was andere wäre ich kümmere mich um
die
das blöd dass wir beide immer diese bot
diese quests machen müssen
es ist irgendwie schon wissen die athris
automatisieren dann können wir das quasi
ja da haben beide das detail gemacht so
zu sagen wenn man einmal einen baum
format haben sie beide so zu sagen weiß
ich meine unter cobblestone eine farm
reichte aber wenn der eine zum beispiel
sein brauchen das ganze museum dazu
bekommen muss der andere das eher normal
machen dann einfach doppelte machen dass
das kriegen wir schon irgendwie
domicilium ich kann jetzt mal kurz
gucken ob da hinten das auch auf erde
jetzt dich übertragen dieser scheiß
genitalbereich nicht immer mehr
durchlaufen muss ich die krise so
schauen wir mal da hinten ob das dich
übertragen lässt auf die erde dass wir
natürlich super das funktioniert weiter
warten warten warten
das ist kurz
jetzt warten hat ein ende
ende april in der perle wochenende dann
können wir mit dem virgin in sachen
tausch können wir richtig gute sachen
von ihm bekommen von wem vom boss nein
merchants diesen anderen menschen da ist
dak inland zufällig gut dass es lösen
sind es macht der nacht nach erwarten
weil wählen wir eine n tabelle haben
können jetzt gegen kaktus tauschen und
sagten zu uns dass wir uns dann wissen
solch sehen und wenn wir noch ein
bisschen fleisch haben
glaubst du es wächst so einfach so
einfach so ein normaler einfach so
baumstamm und dann so eine kokosnuss
dran und jobs ist ex klub sicher am
baumstamm
ja das ist grob muss nicht irgendwie der
höhe sein
ja aber das ist das wirklich so gerade
hier war ich habe gerade gesehen dass es
mit ziel im römer wechsels wegen gehe
ich jetzt mit ein bisschen er da hin und
fordern werde
ja das wächst darüber auf dass sowie mit
gras quasi
das ist glock wieder sehr gut das
abbauen sonne liegt hat spektakel
ich denke es könnte erstens gut sein und
zweitens sind müssen ja auch recht
verzaubern
ich hab ich so einen deal gemacht mit
dem merger mit dem wechsel war nie voran
kommt und wie siehst du dran kommen wenn
die erde
ich habe da kommt runter gesetzt wird
nachgedacht zustand so schön japan gehen
dass man zeit acht minuten
ich weiß jetzt dass wächst weiter aber
heute nacht haben jedoch erst ich
brauche ich brauche monster also ende
männer brauchen wir sowieso durch unser
rauchen wie die wahlkarten enemy no
jetzt wo jetzt was wo wann einer wer
nicht fragt bleibt dumm
ja also deswegen frage ich ja auch du
nicht hier um getorkelt als es geregnet
hat aber da ich glaube der cdu verliert
gemütliche die ganze zeit dass unsere
komische baum familie besser so wir sind
beide gerade voller gedanken weil wir
beide grad was produktives machen
allerdings wäre ein echtes zu übrigens
lücken ja auch gebrauchen
swiss trading system da aber das ganze
ist echtes richtig gute start die haben
einfach die einzigen die man braucht
dadurch kann sie eingefügt durch
anführungszeichen ungewöhnlicher ob das
gut ist das nicht machen wir werden das
nicht unterstützen
zwei stück 3 jetzt ist okay wenn nur
noch die flammen doch ist es nichts mehr
gibt es aber noch ein apfel nur noch 1
nur noch ein einziges brocken fleisch
werden als eben noch besser
hast du es gewachsen können dieses
gewachsen
denn ein platz eben noch mal drum rum
mehr davon kein baum mehr gehalt
aber gesetzliche von so gut von diesem
von von diesem baum ja von diesem baum
hier da fichten den nicht übersetzten
nehmen wir doch nicht schon wieder
hinten
wir haben doch keiner setzt sich gerade
da muss noch einkaufen
egal holz haben ja auch genug ich
brauche keinen keinen sex davon mehr und
du hast auch du also allerdings kennt
man ja alles kurz sind
nach dem cut ich tausche das neue ihm
ganz kurzen dann mach ich das okay
es waren viele viele viele monster
unbedingt rüstung und einsamer danke wir
brauchen hilfe
was heißt eigentlich eigentlich ist das
volkacher wir brauchen uns gar nicht
fürchten beim runterfallen
wir behalten alle sachen so jedoch
deswegen ergeben weil wir nicht haben
wollen so ihre ach so erhöhe gut zu
kennen oder was kein türke ich bin bin
ich sterben wollen
885 scheiße abruf scheiße ja schon
ziemlich einfach noch rein
ich hatte heute ein projekt wie new ja
weißt du sowas ist richtige kamikaze
moral
wer fällt runter dieses scheiß gelernt
und trotzdem trotzdem noch einen pfeil
renner und obwohl er genau weiß ich
werde sterben so ein bisschen so
japanische moral
ich hatte hier versetzt den runde bei
tropenholz feld glaube ich nie ein
setzling runter kommt mir irgendwie vor
wer wollte nochmal der hand complete ich
hab gerade aus erhalten was das traurig
motte wir hatten nicht zufällig schon
einen eimer er hat mir nicht immer einig
nein nein nein er kannst du einholen
ja ich habe eigentlich mein direkter als
oppenheimer hasst man
ja wir machen ganz kurz noch mal am cut
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder bei
zehdenick am nächsten tag mit einem
eimer